Avatar was despite the special effects  one of the least interesting and least  inventive films ever released it was  essentially just Disney's Pocahontas but  with blue people and less singing it was  a film so lacking in wit and creativity  that the natural resource that everyone  is fighting over in the film and it's  called unobtainium because you know it's  difficult to obtain that that's the  level of writing we got in this film it  was the kind of film where the bad guy  is an evil army officer with a scar on  his face who's motivated to do bad  things because you know he's the evil  bad guy and that's what evil guys do and  I would continue in my critique of the  movie but it was so utterly forgettable  that there isn't much else I can really  say about it I will say that it was uh  one of the only times in my life that I  almost walked out of a movie in the  theater only reason I didn't is that I  actually fell asleep